un peu partout sur l'Î de la réunion
entre 200 et 2000 m d'altitude une
plante s'impose comme une redoutable
pionnière ces graines sont capable de
germer dans de très faibles quantités de
matière organique et les plantules sont
en mesure de se développer et de grandir
en plein soleil les écarts de
température entre le jour et la nuit
peuvent beaucoup varier et l'arrosage
dépend uniquement de ce que le ciel peut
envoyer les réserves étant
inexistante en altitude on le trouve
même parmi les quelques effrontés qui
pousse autour des sophoraas c'est donc
une plante robuste capable de
s'implanter n'importe où et qui fait
partie des premières à investir des
lieux qui deviendront un jour un peu
grâce à elle des forêts tropicales cette
plante c'est le bois de piment c'est un
arbre qui ne devient pas très grand
quelques mètres tout au
plus on le trouve sous de nombreuses
morphologies lié aux différents habitats
où il se
développent des veines vert claires sont
remarquablement dessinées sur les
feuilles qui poussent de façon opposée
plutôt à l'extrémité des branches
laissant de grandes parties d'entre
elles dégarnies dégarniis pas tout à
fait les fleurs y ont trouvé leur place
exaltant en grappe serré leur hectare
appétissant
ell pousseent directement sur le bois
des branches on dit qu'elles sont
coliflor la plante est dioque il y a des
plantes qui produisent des fleurs mâles
et des plantes qui produisent des fleurs
femelles mais la différence est très peu
marqué c'est peut-être pour mieux
attirer les animaux qui avident de leur
nectar viennent visiter une à une les
minuscules fleurs sans se soucier de
savoir de quel sexe elles
sont la AR ver profitent des heures
chaudes de la journée pour prendre
délicatement du bout de leur langue le
miel offert par chaque
fleur les oiseaux Verts ne perdent pas
de temps ils passent rapidement et avec
une habilité certaine d'une plante à une
autre tendant le bec ça et là àide de
liquide
sucré c'est quand on voit les fruits du
bois de piment qu'on comprend enfin
pourquoi il se nomme ainsi
les petits fruits sont éissés en épill
tout autour des
branches postés sur des points
stratégiques les merles attendent le bon
moment le bon moment pour que les fruits
soient mûs et éclatant deux laissant
apparaître leur festin une pulpe orange
gorgé de
graines le bois de piment a développé
des aptitude incomparable pour attirer
une grande diversité d'animaux
multipliant ainsi les chances de produ
un très grand nombre de graines et de
les transporter à l'assaut de nouvell
terre à
conquérir